it's been very hard for me to get
through this show up to this point and
not forget about what happened last
night so I need to take this moment to
acknowledge the tragedy the tragic
killings assassinations and the
senseless endings of precious life that
occurred last night in Paris I know
it's disturbed me all day and it's been
really hard actually to get through the
show because in many ways I feel I feel
torn like why am i up here dancing and
having fun when people are crying over
the loss of their loved ones however
that is exactly what these people want
to do they want to shut us up they want
to silence us and we won't let them
we will never let them